[Music]
oh
[Music]
bye
[Music]
we're the same tools in the hands of a
master this ends here
our true memories are still there how
dare you ignore them we were hoping to
put it off for a hundred years or so i
shall
fight by their side now and forever i'm
tired of this world
and everybody in it but i'll become his
sword
one last time no
[Music]
thanks for always being there for me
okay hello everyone oh there we go
and then put the webcam on and then we
do this
hi um sorry to keep you all waiting i'm
not late for any of the reasons anyone
in chat said
uh i was just having trouble getting my
audio to work
um couldn't hear the game which happens
sometimes
unfortunately but we've done it just
want to make sure it's working
it looks like it is success i think
vice you dumbass i think we're good
start making
okay so we are playing a replicant it
just came out today this is basically
a uh remake of neon replicant which
originally only came out in japan but
there was
a version that came out in other regions
which was just near which i have still
in australia sitting on my shelf in
plastic always intended to play it but
never did
played near automata absolutely loved it
um and i feel like it being remade was
like very exciting to me because i
always knew that i would go back and
experience
nia uh getting to do it as part of a
remake is is more exciting so
we have the audio working everything is
okay
i do not know what happens in this game
which
is especially exciting to me i'm a
little bit scared to stream in if i'm
being honest because i know people
really love the story and i hope it
doesn't get spoiled for me
um do have to thank square enix for
giving me a code i am playing on xbox
series x
and i will be sorry a remaster yes
you're right i said the the wrong phrase
but you know what i mean
um and then after we stream here i will
be jumping over to twitch because i am
still allowed to do that i didn't sign
any major exclusivity contract because
they suck
so um i just can't stream them both at
the same time so we're doing youtube for
the first hour so i can leave this up
for anyone who wants to see gameplay was
basically my intent
and then we'll jump over twitch to the
rest of it so let's
go tell me how the audio mix is should
be okay
hopefully
okay cool
i'm really excited normal
oh that's me
is it supposed to be my own name yeah
it's fine it's fine who cares
okay yes
this is not how i expected this to start
not that i know what i expected
it's very pretty so far
it does look like automata as well
though
yeah for anyone who's not familiar
for anyone who's not familiar with uh
with nir in general
um or i guess drakengard as well
people really love these games for
having
a lot of different endings but in a way
that is actually genuine and interesting
um not just like they're all slightly
the same
it's more of a way that they tell
stories which i think is really unique
it's very cool audio too loud let me put
it down as much there you go
summer 2053 also automata
or automata has one of my favorite
soundtracks in any game ever
absolutely love it
[Music]
so this is already very good
[Music]
cool boots man
[Music]
like if link went ema link joined a boy
band
nope well i wasn't that far off
it's still sort of there oh thank you
what
i uh unboxed the collector's engine
today and did get that god damn you guys
saw that
[Applause]
[ __ ]
also yeah i didn't mention trying to
raise 50 thousand dollars for ablegamers
charities which uh helps save games play
video games
[Applause]
okay
that checks out get away you freaks
i'll kill you all
[Laughter]
it's another emo link
[Laughter]
i'm sorry it'll stop in a second
i promise
[Laughter]
it looks great i think this looks really
nice are they
are they gonna come back for me
don't worry jonah i won't let those
things anywhere near you
sit tight i'm gonna go see if i can find
something to eat
is that lined up damn it just
snap oh yeah
don't touch that book not ever
got it got it
i'm already very curious same va as
nines i don't
imagine so but i don't know i've uh you
know obviously
had always planned to to play the first
game again stoked when this was
announced
um
damn how many of these things are um but
i have intentionally not looked up much
about it
again that the series is so story heavy
that i just didn't
won't let you lay a finger on yonah i do
not know much about it other than it
sounds like laura bailey's
and obviously
[Music]
how do you see man i say with the hair
of my own face
it's gotta be tough it's gotta be tough
i respect it
it can't be easy i'm quiet
there you go i need
more power
i need to protect
i believe of the things i do know the
relationship between
him and yonah is one of the main
differences
between replicant and just regular nia
but again i've avoided anything
all right that's an ability i have
okay
is this is this a thing you could let me
do in combat
is this a situation oh it's literally
from the book
[Music]
i've lowered the game a little bit and
i've raised myself hopefully that's okay
uh this is before
so can i use book in combat
yes cool
this combat's great already a big fan
so this is the power of the black book
definitely not doing a great job of
aerial combo type stuff right now so
like is it on a cool now oh my god
it's the coolest wow
dude i want a book that punches people
it's true peace i could get away with
being a new protagonist yeah
okay i'll be the doc lost
okay so it's kind of similar to uh
all the attack on magic buttons to
charge your attacks alternate effects
okay
um
[Music]
sorry not not too different to the
mechanical
i i think this is a very cool opening
for a video game
it's like just a kid trying to
[Music]
quickly i'm like suspicious
[Music]
[Music]
wrong way but wrong way do that again
[Music]
i am thinking about the parts yes
okay
[Music]
it's so good ah that was also very good
[Music]
look at how many levels i'm gaining
[Music]
i'm really not locking me in on various
people very much i'm sure that's going
to be a thing that i will end up having
to
focus on a lot more what is this
need i take need i take you out i do
what did i do did i lose my punch though
let's go that's fake
that's nice the animation man
um i know this game is not flatter but
uh i'm just loving the same people
[Music]
um i bring this up with some frequency i
went to a
dice that included
you know how to make sure that
very fast-paced kind of
hack-and-slashing uh gameplay like this
is satisfying
and a lot of it's to do with making sure
that you have the exact
right frame between a button press and
the feedback that you would get from
that like making sure that the animation
lost the right amount of time hits the
right amount of time they iterate on it
over and over and over again
until they're happy with it basically
hey
all right anyone else oh my god we've
done it
yoda i did watch the opening trailer
chris yes
[Music]
she was just chilling in here surely
she's fine she's not been no one's been
in there
i thought it was gonna do the final
fantasy music for a second
[Music]
my hands yet
both of my wrists which makes any game
that requires pressing one button
that was part of what made auto mods if
i ever needed
[Music]
is
evade is so cool how do i get help
that's my question how to do aerial
combat
d2 at once
ah it's too late to jump in
oh
[Music]
jump
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm not evading very much
of this big weird i don't know tech bro
for the dude
[Music]
i don't know how else you describe him
oh are we having health problems
i gotta get it back though i'm not sure
how that works
[Music]
dammit
[Music]
big ones don't break it don't break it
[Music]
seriously what are they are they like
tech trees like
it's very interesting design
all right get in there buddy you are no
longer this world
no oh
okay okay okay come on get out of here
get out of here
beautiful all right i can turn audio
down
tiny bit there you go maybe there is
that all right
i'm also just not speaking uh i can
increase my point actually hang on
microphone up by five
maybe how's that
now i should be a little bit louder uh
yes neo this was made before
automata correct
oh i didn't listen to what it just said
to me that's my vat
all right okay cool
i'm extremely into it okay now i go
check on
stupid other emo link
hello turns out she's still laughing
shocking
jonah talk to me it's okay
i'm fine what about you those guys were
nothing
okay good hey by the way
look at this i found it while you were
gone
wow is that a cookie hell yeah dude
here we can split it i love apocalyptic
cookies
is audio okay you need to eat two good
seems good cool fine i'll take the small
half
no come on you need to keep up your
straight
so did we just hit 12 500
i will check that off to this emotional
scene yoda
yoda oh no
she's clearly very sweet and you are
supposed to know that immediately
[Music]
he was very specific about not touching
the book so
i just wanted you no jonah
[Music]
life's not great in 2058 looks like
please somebody we need help
i'm right here i'll help you out i got
you i got you
uh oscar the link to my twitch is in the
description should be
yeah we'll jump over there to give away
the codes and stuff i just wanted to put
the first hour of gameplay up on youtube
for anyone who wants to see gameplay
basically i didn't want to
when i parted on twitch completely
stopped making um
youtube stream stuff happen so i will
probably pretty often do like the first
hour of gameplay on here leave the vault
up so that content is still here
okay is very good at what he does
um before we jump over to twitch for the
rest of it
[Music]
yeah something bad happened out here huh
nuclear winter or something
i don't know
[Music]
but it doesn't look good
i don't i disagree
i think you're wrong that's me
maybe it needed me to do that
to start the game
it's not iced coffee timothy just
regular coffee oh
okay that's a change of tone well
several years later it does actually
make sense that it would be a little bit
different now that i think about it
it's all my brothers and sisters we all
look like this i just need blue eyes
my whole family's in this game look at
us go
oh this is uh oriented like the space
station
can i come with you today better not i'm
probably going hunting
i did not expect
that to be what happened here
if i had known i would never have called
this character
alana i just thought it was asking my
name for conversational purposes
and here we are okay but i'll bring you
back a book from the library
okay did not mean
to do that maybe i could change it
i'll see you later try and get some rest
this is very pretty i guess i'll talk to
him
i love you oh my god somebody loves me
oh my god okay hang on let me um take a
look at the donations super quick
i don't want to spend too much time
doing this because this is supposed to
be showing the gameplay
for youtube purposes but also donating
to charity very important
i would think so thank you to duplechy
who said i did it wrong
they tried to smooth the number out
that's incredible uh to leo to anthony
dennis lindsey
and i think slam it as well in here
thank you guys so much
12 550 raise money for ablegamers until
we hit
50 000 it's gonna take a while um okay
let's keep moving with
weirdly masculine sounding alana not
that my voice isn't deep too you know
what i'm saying oh okay
just lying around out here alright okay
it
i should go to the library and see what
popola is up to i hate it
it's a cool fit though it's nice it's a
nice tunic
you've got there i'm liking the ponytail
we actually do have a pretty similar
hairstyles today i just need whatever
that weird
cross thing is and then it's actually
not that far
off if i maybe just sort of like do a
kind of
like this am i doing it
does it look good do we look like the
same person
it's too much it's too much okay
keep rolling this is where i live
dude you [ __ ] you got yourself a fort
that's
sick i hear chickens
can i kick them no but i can kill them
interesting
cool
no auto saves then oops
that's a high jump you've got there
beautiful
this is so pleasant
okay hey who are you
explain yourselves stop working and play
with me for once
this i need to turn those settings off
huh hello
i can't bat the dog
[Music]
the multiple dogs there's
two of them oh my gosh
[Music]
hey come on let's play sorry i've got
work to do
i don't know also your definition of
playing seems to be running around in
this exact circle
is this like what is this what you are
after is this what you thought
we should be doing morning
morning hey devola you keep running
around like that
you're gonna trip and fall on your face
i think i'll be okay but thanks for the
warning don't like that your name's
alana i'm
not comfortable with it hello there's no
better sight than children in high
spirits
it makes me feel young just looking at
them
cute okay
i'm very into this aesthetically so far
we're just gonna we're gonna do some
exploring oh okay
all right it's a lot more fantasy than i
expected even from the
i think generally good rule just for
anyone
to watch out for wolves i think we can
all agree
uh gotta be careful but appreciate the
advice
great we tried let me just do one that's
not ariel nope
okay never mind
okay what was this dog hello what are
you barking at
my friend my tiny brown friend would
upset you so much
hello oh my god
sure wish i had a nice girl like yonah
in my family
i don't know
okay that's
anyway um moving on other people to talk
to
my husband guards the eastern gate and
he keeps staying later and later
if you see him at night tell him to come
home early for once
okay you being cheated on for sure fam
i'm sorry about that some of the gay
guards make a habit of coming home late
um i don't know stefano i've not played
it but so far i'm very into it but i
think
i wonder what's for dinner yeah you're
getting cheated on
oops i keep pressing a to talk i'm all
by myself cause mom and dad are working
and i'm bored you should try running
around in circles i hear the kids
love doing that around here
why not fill your garden with flowers
i'd love to
this seems like a bad thing for me to do
right now
are you telling me i can do farming
stuff in this game
it's even better than i expected
[Music]
i don't think i should commit to this
until i understand it florist
but i am stoked that you exist and about
the possibilities that this could
mean for me and my sick yard
out the front of the fort you know what
i'm saying
okay i'm just gonna we're just gonna
explore
do the speed run do it do it do it
yeah go full naruto sure hope yona gets
better
i think popola's weak cool haircut dick
yeah i know well i'm trying to meet
everyone
i don't know what is google doing eve i
don't understand what you're saying
i wanted to become a rich man for my
girl but it's not going as well as i'd
hoped
oh you can't post links um i guess i'll
just have to save up
that's okay i mean that's one of the
reasons we swapped to streaming on
twitch
primarily is it's just much more i don't
need street friendly just being with him
makes me happier than anything oh
that's so cute you guys should make out
which frankly i'm sort of weirded out
this date seems to be going poorly
like i would think if you're on the top
of this under the tree looking over this
view and you're not making out
something has gone wrong
no picnic blanket you're just sort of
standing under a tree it's all right
it's all right you know maybe you'll get
that people move at different speeds you
know what i'm saying
uh yeah the links should all be in the
description
um it's just gonna be
it's going to be youtube moderating
okay well i don't have to talk to
everyone
but i want to did i talk to you you
aren't out hunting today no i'm supposed
to go to the library but instead i'm
being very social
so
can i go again hello
my sister's gonna rake me over the coals
if i don't get my shopping done soon
she's a real slave driver and if i
wasn't scared of her i'd tell herself
well
you just told a complete stranger on the
street so i'm sure it'll get back to her
in no time
we've got some nice materials in stock
if you want to take
what you get
yes these are materials that exist yeah
you just took the same berries that i've
been getting from the trees
from the ground and you charge 200
g for them life savings is 100 g right
now
okay jeff bezos
everything kind of profiteering is that
expensive lately i guess the sheep are
getting kind of crazy so
people don't want to hunt them oh that's
interesting
it's a very common australian phrase
actually it's not common at all it's
just my grandma says it the phrase
mutton dressed up as lamb
it always makes me think of that
whenever i hear that one
oh i don't but i'm super into it
surrounded by cliffs
folks say you can find a number of
unusual ores there but
it's a rough area great
um okay i really should get to this
library
it's going to be is that that's
home i assume i don't know how to read
this map
is the red x where i need to go
where is that home no i think i probably
need to go to the red x as much as i
would like to
hang out and explore here we're gonna
take off in the direction of the x and
see what happens
which i believe is going to be up this
way
this music's beautiful pigs
got it all compact those either though
is this it no
so i think that this is just leading me
to my house right like that's what the x
is
i'm unclear because i can't see a way to
interact with the map unless i'm hiding
it
on my own screen i'm not sure
i should not talk about my other boss
like that who owns twitch i'll talk
about about twitch
i don't care does not concern me
and they don't pay me technically i
generate revenue for them visiting
popular again today
yes let's go
i really [ __ ] up i really made a
mistake
that is my bad oh boy um okay
this is also really nice dude i think
i'm gonna love this game
that's that's i'm putting it out there i
think i'm gonna have a great time
um all right we're gonna take it slow
we're gonna explore we're gonna talk to
people
right now i think we need to go
this way yes
hello good morning how's yona doing
today
seemed fine when i left her cough's
still pretty bad sorry metal coff's
still pretty bad
that's worrisome i know i keep hoping
she'll at least get a little better
but i don't know i feel like i'm failing
her
no stop that you're the finest brother a
girl could hope to have
anyway i was hoping you might take care
of this for me
i got a request from someone in the
shopping district
they
[Music]
since you're going to the plains let me
give you a map
thank you trust me it'll come in handy i
don't doubt that
why did you need to say trust you do
people often disagree with you on that
it seems pretty smart
oh interesting and would you mind
purchasing three medicinal herbs from
the client while you're at it
sure i used my last one earlier here's
some money
she's a very cute choice this is way too
much
well then buy some for yonah while
you're at it
you don't have to it's okay really was
she come some kind of rich librarian
are you the one that's selling the
berries for the 100 profit papala
i thought you were one of the good ones
thanks popola what's this all about
just the way you and the other villagers
always take care of us
we really appreciated us all
think nothing of it people need to look
out for each other
right besides everyone here wants to see
yonah healthy and happy
so hang in there okay i will
it's so cool kind of just want to look
around the library a little bit this
place is beautiful and i would love to
go here in real life
you got anything for me to pick up
or anything hello
hello
what kind of books you like go what are
you reading here you uh
it's like romance novels or
what kind of fiction are we talking
asked me to organize the books you sound
suspiciously like there were so many
i never should have taken this job i'll
help if you
can is there maybe do you need help
with anything
asked me to organize the books but i had
no idea there were so many
i never should have taken this job well
um you're the most beautiful thing i've
ever seen let me know if you need any
help bye
just imagining librarians hanging out
like that damn
oh what a devastating world we live in
when no librarian is dressed like that
you know hello yonah
oh hey what jonah you're supposed to be
in bed you can read
see now your ribbon's all undone i'm
sorry
i just thought i'd see if the library
had any books about how to cure my
sickness
jonah look don't worry you just need to
eat and rest
you really think so i know so anyway
i've got work to do so i need you to
head home deal
as someone who is very sick as a child
i'm i'm kind of feeling this
like wanting to go out and do stuff and
people always being like you should
probably
not but what if you get asthma and die i
say the world is dying
populations continue to fall all plague
and disease run rampant
if that wasn't enough monsters called
shades now roam the land as well
threatening our very lives but i can't
let any of that distract me
my sister is sick and my only goal is to
ensure that the two of us survive
it's not easy for a pair of kids to live
on their own it's true
taxes but the villagers have been kind
to us
and despite everything somehow i feel
like we're gonna be okay
we have to be there's no other choice
cool oh my god thank you guys for
watching the spoilers i really don't
want to have this spoiled for me
um when we jump over to twitch i'll put
a bigger mod delay so that
if there are any you can clear them also
sorry to my mods if that
that does that for you it spoils it for
you that would that would be a bummer
did not sell my chair no definitely just
not at home
um okay cool
i think we can probably just keep going
oh i should save
this game likes to save
so far i'm finding this game very happy
except for the fact that i named myself
alana mistakes were made
we've no one's perfect okay we've all
made mistakes
it happens i should
and it's crazy because in most games i
make my character look like this [ __ ]
dude anyway
sort of but i always name him
when you're knocked away you can defend
to recover quickly
imagine walking up to someone and having
them say that to you
oh well thank you
be careful if you head north some of the
sheep in the plains are getting
i feel like this game is setting me up
to be really scared of some sheep
real scared gonna let him make awesome
food for alana i bet
i better start all right where do i get
my own yonah i got an older sister
she'd probably cook for me if i asked to
be fair
i don't think she'd like research a new
recipe but i was like yo hey sarah can
you make me some
stir-fry i feel like she'd be down
okay that's lock on i'll drive a little
left on a
note that the function will cause
whatever is
active am i supposed to fight these
sheep
ah i didn't like it i know that's what
you want me to do
but i didn't love that for me strip
why'd you put your hand in his butt
oh oh my oh heck
there's blood on me nice detail
i'mma strip you okay
yeah gotta get that mutton i think
that's what i'm trying to get right i'm
not actually trying to get the wool
all right i don't know you were spicy
[ __ ] out here
okay
who do you think you are no remorse no
mercy
no rugrats
[Music]
is that all i need
um how much just some money
all right just keep finding some mutton
he was really waiting for me to come
okay did i say how many pieces i needed
did anyone check that to the village
how similar does the combat filter
automata um
super symbol so far uh obviously
you know you level it up really
significantly in that game but um
yeah so far like even the jump height
feels really similar like it's
it's equally fast
man that's pretty just
just she's really animating out here
um yeah it definitely feels similar to
me um really really smooth
again responsive i think i'm having a
little bit of trouble with the camera
but that's totally on me i think i'm
just not
using it correctly just yet early days
definitely not getting any cool combos
and i missed the book already
i have no idea shades were loose so
close to the village
[Music]
oh hi this is zach i definitely don't
stream at ideal times for the uk i'm
sorry about that
but again i do plan to just leave this
up for anyone who um
time to get this meat to the shopkeeper
cool uh who wants to see the gameplay
basically i really would have spent all
of my time
in this village talking to everyone but
i was like it is the purpose of this
video that i was planning to like show
people
kind of the early parts of this game so
i should do a better job of that
uh before we jump over to twitch
in about 15 minutes is it you
here's that mutton you want oh thank you
you wouldn't believe how popular this
stuff has been lately
oh and this isn't much but so i know
that you're selling berries for
200 g you better pay up
i said thanks okay you got it
i take back everything that i said i
just didn't understand
how inflated their economy was
he gave me 600 gold for something that
took me like five minutes
maybe that's fine she did
oh i did wonder about that
cool make sure you stock up on the
session trying to
give me herb
and then wait didn't he say get one for
i'm just gonna buy a couple more
okay come back any time will do thanks
fam
see you later can you stop asking about
yonah
can you okay can you all right mate
okay we are gonna have problems here
[Music]
okay it's fine it's fine
right now i can afford three berries for
those
sheep i hunted
and anime run
hell yeah hey who's this what are you
doing at my save point what are you
doing
young people always drive themselves
forward
but it's important to take a step back
and look around sometimes
makes you think i don't disagree
okay hello
this is home right yeah i just go
upstairs
where's jonah oh well
let's go back to the library find popola
i imagine she's on the same spot
um it's this way i think up the rickety
stairs
it is a fast run speed though
this is very cute the the book updates
very nice it's just a cute touch
everything's cute my main descriptor in
life
okay i delivered the mutton
oh and here's your herbs great
that should help with the food shortage
and thanks for the herbs too
that's all for today you should hurry
back to yonah
you say that but she's not home
something bad's gonna happen isn't it
something some negative yonah related
thing is going to occur
she's not here anymore i'm i'm already
attached it could be really bad
your run speed is at least 50 miles an
hour yeah but it's like just sort of a
trot when he's like this
and then he gets his little wind speed
boost
and he's a god
it's not like that it doesn't stop it's
nice
yonah you better you better be here i
swear to god
okay it's fine welcome home
how'd it go today you saw me like five
minutes ago
i'm sorry you're very kind i just stayed
here all day like youtube that's not
true i saw you at the library
i tried reading books but i finished all
of them
no so if you have any fun what's wrong
with me you should tell me
well popola told me about a legendary
flower called a lunar tear
have you heard of it that's a silly name
i think that's the flower that's on the
uh front of the uh collector's edition
i guess all the but people's
beyond your wildest dreams if i ever
found one
i'd buy you so many cookies you have a
really good relationship i'm already
yeah this game's gonna [ __ ] me about
isn't it
with that kind of money we could buy the
best medicine around
the kind that'll cure anything
uh yonah what's wrong
it's nothing goodnight
i'm really worried about her
no not yet
i'm gonna spend this whole game just
being worried i'm off to popola and
please stay out of trouble today
okay okay
[Music]
i thought i see you at the library again
i swear to god i could you could
literally have the game be nothing but
this and i would be okay with it
just like farming getting berries
helping my stupid sick sister
talking to the hot redhead visiting the
half
naked chick in the library
you've covered all the bases sometimes i
mess up some sheep
discounted veggies she
my heart oh god
why are you doing this to me so fast i
don't think i've ever loved anyone so
much
sup fam hey popola need a hand with
anything
i do have something but i don't know
it's going to be a bit of an ordeal i'm
sure i can handle it
aren't you confident well
you know the little wooden bridge out in
the northern plains right
the one where the pillars all rotted out
exactly
we had a team of carpenters working on
it but they were attacked by shades
i wonder what the shades are i don't
know yet it's so sunny there
yes i know apparently it was overcast
that day
and the shades caught them off okay
that's pretty literal one of the
carpenters was seriously injured
but they can't move him so long as the
shades are there
i'll go take him out if you're up for it
it could be really dangerous
i'll be fine popola i've been training
every day i'm as strong as anyone in the
village
that's not about the government of
confidence that you think it is
just as anyone
okay i killed a bunch of shades by the
village gate just
you did do that yeah that didn't happen
oh that's a bit disconcerting
anyway are you sure you want to take
this job
yes yes i got i'm in it
so that the chick who's reading the
books over here
will fancy me is she still
here
she's passing through don't worry about
don't don't mind me hope yeah
how's your job though are you done you
need help coppola asked me to organize
the books
but i had no idea better just keep
standing there
okay bye let's go let's do it
am i gonna get another nice note from
yonah
no um all righty
back up and out cool cool cool
this gameplay is really fluid it's nice
the video game feels good as it turns
out
they just hate sunglasses it's true
this is maybe the bridge they were
referring to
so once do i need to go oh no it's this
way okay
see is it this
maybe no just keep going
[Music]
not entirely positive where you need me
to land
maybe up that platform
ah that makes sense
[Music]
okay oh oh hello
noted i'll give that a shot oh i killed
him
okay let's try deflect come at me
[Music]
surely that was too early
did that work
there we go cool
[Music]
the dodge is wonderful very good
like it just is so fast
get out of here i'm level three now son
okay strong as anyone in the village
that should take care of the shades for
a while
is that it wow all right
pretty easy job so far again i disagree
you keep saying that but i don't think
it has
maybe i need to use a cable
hmm
okay it's just back through the way that
we came
stupid sheep
hello raisa welcome
why did you guys seem positive about
this this seems like the kind of game
that i feel like a lot of people like
i'm definitely very into this like i'm
already
i was already very excited about it um
again intentionally stayed doc
on it i've tried to avoid you know i
picked up bits and pieces just
by liking mia had it on my shelf in
australia still in its plastic wrap it's
still there i think
um but it's somehow even like i'm
already more into it than i would have
expected
i'm already attached to these characters
and very interested in this world but
it's not
like super combat heavy immediately so
sometimes uh
general audiences are very against that
kind of thing um
when you stream something like this oh
should i go to popular yeah
but i'm very into it i think this is
gonna break my heart though
i'll say that
okay
you're back hey popola did everything go
all right
were you hurt i'm super chill dude
i killed him you should tell your
friends they go with the books you
should tell her
i felt like i sent you into a really
dangerous situation
super chill look at me
i'm fine i know it's just
i'm just everyone's very sweet oh here
those carpenters left some money for you
wow thanks go buy something nice for
yonah okay
why is it always about yonah oh speaking
of yonah
she came by this afternoon why does she
never stay home what
damn she was supposed to stay home i
think it's okay
she just wanted to ask me a question i
feel like she should be fine to go to
the library though
he's been a bit strict you mean outside
the village
exactly she seemed excited too
poor thing was talking about she read
something she's probably been getting
nutty ideas from some book again
don't worry i made sure to remind her
she isn't allowed beyond the gates
thanks but she was curious yeah
i will okay let's go
back on shall we
i hope the soundtrack's on spotify to be
fair i do own it
i do have the discs but also
i would like to play it on spotify
maybe she's still at the library
i didn't see her at the library mate i
don't know if she is
but i also feel like this is the point
where i should stop we're at basically
an hour
um right at this cliffhanger right here
so i'm gonna take
uh probably like five minutes jump over
to twitch for anyone who'd like to join
us
let me see if i can type it in the chat
twitch dot tv slash charlanazon
and um i have a bunch of cards to give
away we've got
six in total i think um we will tie two
charity incentives but really anyone can
win them got multiple platforms
so we can make that happen it's not on
spotify devastating
um i'm very into this i'm sure i'll
probably end up streaming a fair amount
of the game on
uh on twitch um yeah let me know if you
guys have any questions
i'm excited i'm very excited
so we're gonna jump over to twitch right
now i will see you all there
in a moment good day thank you for
watching bye